heute ist mein name 400 euro kostet das
die leute erst im folgenden video wir
trinken gerade vor für den kölner
karneval und ich hatte die sehr
geistreiche idee dass ich einfach ein
video beim laufen drehen
wir haben hier oben eine kamera
irgendwann kann man die werden jetzt
rage cage spielen ist ein spiel was ich
jetzt in meinem aktuellen zustand nicht
erklären kann deshalb werde ich es in
der zukunft mit einem bus aber tun
unsere milch wieder heute wir haben
svenja länger
jakob
sie hat
und sebastian ist auch dabei es wird
sehr lustig ich würde sagen wir reden
nicht lange rum jemand die erklärung von
crossgate ist ein gesellschaftliches
trinkspiel zunächst werden auf einer
tischplatte verschiedene bäche mit
alkoholischen getränken gestellt zwei
gegenüberliegende spieler erhalten einen
tischtennisball und probieren diesen in
einen vor ihm stehenden leeren becher zu
werfen
treffen sie in den becher dürfen sie den
ball ein spieler weitergeben
ziel des spiels ist das ein welcher in
den anderen einholen muss wenn das der
fall ist dann darf dieser löcher in den
anderen hineingestellt werden und der
spieler der eingeholt wurde muss ein
glas aus der mitte nehmen und trinken
eine interessante sonderregel sollte man
den beiden ersten versuchen den becher
werfen dann darf man ihn an eine
beliebige stelle in der runde reichen
und ist somit dem einlochen deutlich
näher und kostüme was seid ihr so du
bist
[Musik]
ich bin ja komplett sie besonders
der euro schoss zunächst bezahlt wie
irgendwann doch die sorten ziemlich
erschreckend ist aber ist möglich auf
den schimmel captain morgan kempten
bigbox prozent ist aus bali reisen
dürfen
durch geht's betreiben 21 also hab ich
schon designs werden macht richtig lust
auf dem trinken
du musst weiter direkt eingesehen
wiederhergestellt werden in diesem video
leuten gekauft eine kurz erklärt gekappt
an bord das insbesondere in aachen
verbreitet ist gekappt bedeutet in etwa
so viel wie geschnarcht gefangen oder
eingeholt im kontext unseres spiels
bedeutet das dass die person die gekackt
wurde von einer anderen person eingeholt
wurde
das heutige
55 ist mir sagte wenn man etwas nettes
zu kriegen sind nächstes wollen wir
müssen es mir ein wenig geschockt das
ist das letzte was übrig bleibt und sich
wieder sagt er und folge komplett euch
das mal dass wir vielleicht das eine
oder andere mal bereits aus der top down
perspektive gesehen haben sind nicht
alle becher mit bier gefüllt sondern wir
haben auch verschiedene zum einen den
ekel stromberg mit bier hinter der
kamera bitte der sieg aber nur da kann
man als stürmer chronik die ich könnte
mich mal ein kommunizieren das ist mein
ding sie betrogen habe der mann mit der
pop da die gute dame fährt einen
hörsturz erzählt er
aber wir haben wurde gekannt richtigen
wir sind wahr
jetzt ist es so weit in die tasche
erwischt sehen wir selbst wie es ihm
damit er geht das ist korrekt
das brunnenfest das sieht aus wie eine
sehr grosse kammer alles gesehen haben
sollten
das alte das sind touristisch weiter
sagt martin schaudt 12 21 nachdem zuvor
der löst fraktion new yorks damals nicht
im ist bei seinem ersten saisonstart
denken jetzt das in der regel nicht
kennen das stimmt aber wer sagt dass net
hat richtig die an den tag gelegte
spielweise entspricht nicht im regelwerk
uns damit ungültig das ist uns ist
dieser 11 und 21
[Applaus]
eigentlich sollte sie mache ich völlig
desinteressiert und vorletzte knallhart
läuft flüssig und verständlich wenn ja
ich doch die katze hat sie was sie
kürzen die köpfe zweier der druck ist
sehr groß auf die halbherzig ja wohl
letzte sekunde ist eine rekombination
ich will noch mal verschickt wird packt
zugesagt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hallo da nichts wenn jetzt die heiße
jetzt 13 12
man wird hier sehr gut geklappt labore
juncker habe die tür
das wort vom team mit fia kommen soll
niko resch ich muss mir erst länder
gezeigt wird und da immer einmal ruhig
dahin so weiter sind typisch für seriöse
das ist es dem eingriff und schafft
dabei aber nichts zu tun das ist nämlich
schon das leben drin als pdf hier
doch was dann drücken wir in den letzten
reihen der einzige der die welt für
meter steht
felix welker kassiert okay das war's vom
heutigen video wir haben wir die ganze
spielwelt
wir werden zum abschluss allerdings
nochmal klopfer drehen spielen in den
reden über dinge auf den derzeit vfb
blau-weiß leinach geht der zuschauer
blickt auch hat nicht nur der werden sie
als landwirtschaftlicher betrieb und je
nach landschaft
[Musik]
[Applaus]